These hands were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for peace
I need to figure out exactly who i am
I want to choose my own path live in the moment
my superheroing days are over
remember what i told you you ever feel lost just
look into the eyes of the people that you love
not me what just listening
Welcome back everyone marvel just dropped a brand
new imax version of the thor love and thunder
trailer with a bunch of extra footage a bunch
of extra easter eggs so we'll break it all down
i just did the same thing for the imax version
of the doctor strange two trailers well i'll
link that below in the description but if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're also doing an imax
ticket giveaway for doctor strange too because
it's coming out in a couple weeks all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite new easter egg from this imax versus the
trailer on the video but at the beginning part of
the trailer when they go through this montage
and you get all the different versions of thor
and all his different costumes that he's worn
you see that classic looking version of the thor
costume from jack kirby's original thor comics
when he first debuted in journey into mystery
it seems like he brings back his gold boots
through all the different versions of the
costume like obviously by the time he gets to his
last upgrade in the movie that blue gold rune king
thor looking costume it's very golden blue but
even when he does his first upgrade after he goes
from trucker thor in the avengers hat strongest
avenger also written in sharpie strongest to the
eric masterson looking thunderstrike 80s costume
which is actually just called ravager's thor like
he's supposed to think of himself as a member of
the ravagers when this is happening he's still got
the gold boots and it sounds like he keeps them
when he gets his next upgrade also the other thing
you probably notice is because that extra imax
footage you see the extra belt buckle that he's
wearing in that second costume upgrade and the
other big thing too is the second costume upgrade
is basically a version of his golden thor costume
that he wore after the mighty thor arc which was
the whole arc that introduced the jane foster
version of thor that's the armor that he wore
in the big thor reboot during volume 5 where he
got the golden hammer and the golden arm he wore
when he became king thor and he wore it during
the war of kings event which was like another
big thor crossover event that pulled in the
rest of the marvel universe but it sort of spun
around the thor comics i think there's actually
a big easter egg in there too what they're doing
with the different characters and the place that
they're taking them to during the movie and how
the thor character evolved between all these
different comic book events but they're kind
of mixing and matching a lot of different events
from where they originally happened in the comics
like think about it this way we all know that
we're eventually headed for a giant secret
wars event in the future of marvel phase five
marvel phase six however soon they decided to do
something like that because this is what's going
on with the thor character right now so they're
obviously doing the mighty thor arc from the
comics where jane foster becomes a version of thor
but the thing during that story arc carrying
through war of kings and then up through
cosmic thor more recently they're kind of doing a
version of cosmic thor in the background too here
is that eventually thor realized that he was
still worthy became a version of king thor but
then eventually got really tired really bored
with being actual king and started dealing with
way greater cosmic threats like the black storm
he became the herald of galactus that's when
actual cosmic thor debuted that version was
almost as powerful as a version of rune king thor
now ruined king thor like i said they're sort
of mixing and matching easter eggs from a bunch
of different comic book story arcs going way
back he was a version of thor who was also on
the path to becoming a version of king thor but
it was a very brief story arc where it became
so powerful so cosmic that he sort of merged
with the essence of the universe and was reborn
and things sort of rebooted ragnarok style so the
whole idea during the trailer thor realizing his
greater cosmic role like i need to find my place
in the universe is then putting him on the path
to becoming a much more cosmic version of thor but
obviously being just slightly different from what
you saw in the comics chris hemsworth said that
he wanted to stick around his store in the mcu
long term but they need to find a way to evolve
the character beyond a lot of the earthly concerns
that he's had he's been so preoccupied with
what's happening around earth around jane foster
he's kind of neglected his duties as an actual
god of the mcu which is where you get to the
gorr of the god butcher storyline a lot of the
gorr storyline is giving him that rune king thor
storyline where it puts him through all these
same types of trials that odin went through when
he was conquering the nine realms and forming
the odin force becoming an actual god himself
and part of the reason for doing this is so in
the background as they sort of spin up for their
version of secret wars when things become really
crazy across the multiverse thor is much more
capable much more able to help and deal with
these multiverse level threats there's a much
better picture of the scene from the gorr comics
this is directly taken from the comics when he
and korg are witnessing a god that gorr has just
killed like they're seeing his aftermath and this
giant rat creature who is a god is actually one of
thor's friends in the comics somebody who he knew
so this is him just learning how serious things
are but it seems like he doesn't totally know
what's going on with gorr yet and this is what
sort of sets him on the path to go back to new
asgard like he's worried he goes back for answers
and he lands there just after gorr has already
attacked like it's in the middle of an attack here
when this is happening jane foster also happened
to be there and also already got the hammer when
he shows up that's why he's so surprised like he
didn't see any of this happening you also probably
noticed the ravager's costume that he wears he has
a brand new shirt underneath that eric masterson
looking jacket the design is sort of like a cosmic
version of the design of the world tree he's also
meant to be under a version of the world tree when
he's meditating on what he's going to do next
bearing stormbreaker in the ground this isn't
meant to be the actual world tree it's just meant
to be like a really large tree the world tree
is sort of like this metaphysical giant cosmic
thing that connects all the nine realms but based
on this extra footage what seems like happens is
that when he goes back to new asgard learns about
jane foster becoming a version of thor learns what
happened with mjolnir being able to reforge itself
because of odin's enchantment just being strong
enough it seems like they all go with korg to
mount olympus to find out what's actually going
on with gorr to try and chase him down and for
those of you asking there is a bit of confusion
here between what happened in the eternals movie
where they come from the comics where the greek
gods come from the comics because some of the
eternals are based on some of the greek gods but
as we learn that's all fakery that's just the
celestials just creating this backstory for them
but the greek gods come from a version of mount
olympus part of the eternal's fake backstory is
that they come from a place called olympia which
is a completely different place in the comics what
it seems like they've done in the mcu though with
russell crowe's version of zeus and his pantheon
of gods is that this version of mount olympus
exists the same way that asgard existed relative
to the earth so like they're saying that this
version of mount olympus is probably a completely
different place on a different planetoid based on
the way this footage plays out it seems like what
happens is the upgrades to the rune king thor
blue gold armor after he goes back to new asgard
before he takes off again and takes the goat boat
with him with the cosmic goats from the comics
the whole thing with the goat boat too is that
it also seems like they've used it in new asgard
because it has cocktails written in neon on it
for all the tourism and when thor goes back and
there's all this chaos with gorr and then he
leaves again to try and chase him down he just
steals the goat boat like okay i'm taking this
and i'm taking a couple of the goats too thor
can use stormbreaker to travel wherever he wants
he doesn't actually need the ghost to do that
i think he's probably just doing this for fun
because he has people with him you see a little
more footage of russell crowe's version of zeus
and it seems like they're setting him up for a
giant kill like gorr is going to show up and just
mow through all these mount olympus greek gods
but i think based on all this extra footage
then putting him on the path to becoming this more
cosmic version of thor he might not literally die
and be reborn but it seems like he'll sacrifice
his life in the process of trying to defeat gorr
and in that process become much more powerful it's
part of the whole idea of norse mythology odin's
trials that he went through to attain even greater
power in how thor went through greater trials than
what odin went through to attain even greater
power than odin had a lot of you also asking
about beta ray bill so because i didn't talk about
him in my previous thor videos the korbinites the
race that he comes from have already been featured
in the marvel movies recently and beta ray bill
himself has already been featured in thor ragnarok
he was actually supposed to be featured on screen
but kevin feige said that they saw the footage
of him and then realized that his storyline was
going to be kind of short so they decided to just
save him for a storyline where they could feature
him much more fully but that's why you saw beta
ray bill's face on the grand masters tower he
was meant to be one of the previous winners of
the contest of champions beta ray bill's version
of stormbreaker from the comics that hammer was
also featured in the background of the collector's
warehouse during guardians of the galaxy during
the time heist mission when they're back in 2014
and they show you what thanos is doing attacking
this planet they're fighting these giant creatures
in armor suits those are korbinites they're on
the korbinite home world when this is happening
so that's beta ray bill's home planet beta ray
bill was actually a regular korbinite who was
upgraded with technology to become this cyborg to
fight against fire lord surter and his fire demons
but it seems like what they're doing for him
in the mcu as part of this backstory is they're
saying that thanos before he got all the infinity
stones basically took his entire army and balanced
his planet old school style and that's what caused
them to turn beta ray bill into the cyborg version
of himself then somehow he wound up in the grand
masters contest of champions wound up winning that
and we'll just see what's happened to him
since then so if you spotted any other new
things in the imax version of the trailer with
the extra footage that i didn't talk about in
the video just write them below in the comments
everyone click here for my moon knight episode
5 trailer video and click here for my full
moon knight episode 4 video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!